foreign
good evening first from our
investigators here at six o'clock the
Nevada Gaming Control Board disrupting
an alleged embezzlement scheme costing a
sports betting company some big bucks a
news now investigator David charns is
live in studio joining us now with these
exclusive details tonight David well
Denise and Brian we have learned Gaming
Control Board investigators suspect
employees at sports betting company
William Hill altered kiosks all across
the valley to steal money now documents
the news investigators obtained revealed
Paige Steiner who appeared here in court
this morning faces
270 charges for her alleged role records
showing several people are tied to this
case including a now fired William Hill
supervisor who detectives say was in
charge of reviewing these adjustments
now this is what those betting kiosks
look like Caesars owns William Hill
gaming board investigators alleged
Steiner and others would call customer
service to say they had an issue with
one of these machines those
investigators allege the person working
looking at a Las vegas-based office
would then alter the transaction costing
the company hundreds of thousands of
dollars over time
this appears to be a situation where you
were the person depositing the initial
voucher and the co-conspirator was the
one working for the casino and was
adjusting the amount on the voucher to
increase that amount
Steiner and that former employee both
appearing in court today both are right
now out of custody two others also
facing charges now we have learned
Williams William Hill that is their own
internal investigators found two
simultaneous alleged embezzlement
schemes right now it is unclear if they
are related in any way we did ask the
company for a comment and we did not
hear back I'm David Charles 8 News Now